you know you brought up news and stuff
you were in the military for many years
did you ever kill anybody no really
thought about it didn't do it so when
you're in the service you just think
about killing people but you didn't do
it but you did see action I I was in I
was in some uh uh uh situations but I
never had to it it was not called upon
so didn't have to when you're in a war
situation but killing was not called
upon mhm were you in a were you I know
you're a marine right and what was your
job uh I had uh a couple different jobs
I did uh public affairs which do they
send you out public affairs well that's
one of them I would escort media around
the battlefield so they didn't get
killed wow and then uh I did Civil
Affairs which I went out into the local
population and I would work with the
local
mulas officials whoever was a leader and
uh see if there was ways that uh we
could help
them um in what do you speak another
language I don't I don't I have a
masters in in in public administration
and I think that's why they connected
the two so they were like oh well then
why don't you go do civil Affairs uh and
get out in town talk to the local mulas
and we'll help them build schools we'll
help them with their roads because like
Afghanistan had no infrastructure at all
at all so you know there's no courts
there's no hospitals there's no it just
things were really crappy right so we
would go and and my job was to Liaison
with them now the military's job is not
to build your nation uh the military job
is to provide a safe environment so that
Red Cross peace winds all these other
non-governmental organizations can come
in and do their good work right but
they're not going to come in and do work
in a war zone we have to make it safe so
I with the military makes it safe ia's
on with the locals I tell the the Moola
yeah with the mulas on occasion uh and I
tell the uh NOS it's safe you can come
in you can start doing your work hey
Moola meet Red Cross Red Cross meet M an
NGO a non-governmental organization okay
wow and so so that you know it depended
but those were the two primary jobs that
that I would do and I'd always be
attached to a unit so I would be
attached to Third Battalion fist Special
Forces or the 22nd Marine Expeditionary
Unit or to you know whatever CU I was
more of an individual floater so I
worked on staffs did you come close to
uh violence yeah yeah in Kosovo I was
shot at several
[Music]
times